now you said it's a costume party and i
was called balls baby this is called
balls and i like it
now let me give your costume the proper
intro it deserves so from the current
queen of halloween
repping
her own bloodlines original scream queen
janet that was pretty good right not bad
i'm i'm honoring my beautiful late mama
janet lee but i'm actually it's a little
more meta than that
i'm actually going as scarlett johansson
as janet lee
in the movie hitchcock so it's meta
i know
because we never knew what color janet
lee's dress was because it was a black
and white movie but now because of the
hitchcock movie we know it was pale blue
knowledge bombs being dropped and mommy
did a little diy uh
art project the other day i was worried
you would see this and think i just
looked like a 50s housewife and so i
thought
you know
maybe i need a
little bloody uh
shower curtain
yeah it all makes sense now let's
speaking of blood you dealt with a lot
of blood in this movie what's it like
the cleanup process of washing blood
hollywood blood off you know it's
actually quite sticky and it stains
so it takes a little bit here's my
secret for those who are interested dish
soap
like a good dish soap
will actually get out fake blood
there you go again knowledge bombs i
appreciate it
um by the way
i'm just beyond that you're doing this
it by the way
it is a well by the way oh hi michael
sorry you know i tried earlier too i
know
anti-social a little bit
very um okay you're just killing me
you're killing me
thank you
um
i wanted your nuts
i lost them a long time ago i think okay
i think this is devolving right um hold
on 30th anniversary of my girl is coming
up i wanted to bring that up real quick
can you talk about it can you just give
me my girl oh my goodness me
um
[Music]
you know what it was beautiful it was a
beautiful movie my girl it was a
beautiful movie was very lucky to be in
it and uh
has a lot of nostalgia for me i could
come up with silly things to say but
it's actually a beautiful movie so i'm
not going to crack jokes because i've
already you know
cracked a couple
jamie curtis you're nuts you're cracking
a couple jokes
i'm the butt of all jokes jamie thank
you i love you
commitment
for all you people out there like oh do
i go in a costume or not commitment
jamie lee curtis says it it's true facts